morning Millennials men it feels good to
say that live and in living color it is
so exciting for me to be back I know
you're RDH about it I'm not that upset
like I'm I'm sitting in the chair and
like I'm not mad about it but I did miss
like getting an extra 30 minutes cuz I
didn't put makeup on this week and I
really there was something I really
liked about being a podcaster like in a
studio I really felt like Howard Stern
but I understand that that's not the
life we chose and I'm fine with that oh
and it was it was nothing of the sort
for me sorry it was somebody lied to you
somebody lied to me and told me that I
was gonna enjoy it and I really didn't
but like now today back in the studio
like back on the air I am feeling like
nervous yeah well I definitely got a
little comfortable like knowing that
there was a safety net of like if you
say something stupid like you can cut it
out and that is a really good feeling
like I'm not gonna lie but you know what
again that's not the life we chose for
ourselves and we're just gonna have to
be okay with that yeah I mean I'm okay
with it I'm happy to be back with you
back with everyone it's Friday it's been
like a hell of a week truly like a very
rewarding but challenging and busy week
like lots of challenges with our studio
which is always frustrating but that's
what it means to be a business owner
lots of personal challenges in the sense
that I have a lot of work to do that I
just like haven't been doing so I'm
gonna get on that today for sure yeah
I've just been busy and and that's
always good cuz you know I've been not
busy and that's [ __ ] depressing yeah
also lots of tragedy this week lots of
new coronavirus outbreaks this week I'm
like hypersensitive like I really don't
feel like dying like things are just
getting good for me like I had to if
there was ever a time for me to die it
would have been March 2018 but like I
made it and I'm not [ __ ] dying right
now okay so keep your germs the [ __ ]
away from me totally it's an you guys
like I know even talking about
coronavirus everyday talking we have
been talking about it but you said it's
really it's really serious yeah it's
really serious and there's something
they're not telling us all about this
serious man it's like a controversial
opinion now like it's so funny how like
in this like sensitive culture like
weird things become like controversial
and being like shook by coronavirus now
makes you controversial because it's
like the flu kills 50,000 people a year
like no one cries about that I'm like
nobody's died from coronavirus in Amer
but it's like are we not supposed to be
afraid no I haven't heard anything of
the sort oh why this is a controversial
opinion oh it is you know what I just
don't go looking for these things like I
see what I see
and I make up my opinion the difference
of someone who has a Twitter and someone
who doesn't yeah and so you know what
you guys current virus-like stay safe
out there stay safe out there just be
clean wash your hands even though Jackie
told me it's a respiratory contagion so
it's like so you can get it from like
breathing in contagious air you can also
get it from like touching contact so do
wash your hands and just and be mindful
I'm just thinking I'm like not gonna see
anyone for a while like personally it's
just not something I'm interested in and
then also getting coronavirus is really
something I'm not interested in so I'm
just thinking it's gonna be a secluded
weekend for me like I was thinking maybe
I would try and be thirsty and try to
get my ass to SNL tomorrow like to see
Luke combs perform but one there's so
many people and like you know
coronavirus could be in the air - it's
always a better viewing experience
watching something from home like the
Super Bowl like we went to the Super
Bowl once it was couldn't see anything
was so fantastic you guys was amazing i
bielice we had an incredible time yeah
I'm not even gonna lie and pretend like
I didn't like it I did but I'd like it's
much more it's made for TV it is I
really look forward to watching Luke
Holmes JJ Watt in my bed on Saturday
night the joy still I'm not even trying
to get there the jury's still out on
whether or not I'm a first up and try
and use my sense some of my connections
to end up at SNL and then like roll
myself into Lorne Michaels office and be
like I'm a star I just sold out the
Beacon Theater it put me on your show
that's okay well if you're gonna be
networking it's different right no it's
it's actually a work thing like I have
to go just me being thirsty and I'm just
not interested I like um and I'm happy
for you I don't know that I'm I don't
think that I'm done yet in the phase of
my life where like I'm done being
thirsty I think I'm almost reaching my
end like I'm just getting too old for
this but I think I still got like a good
two years in May good there's doubt it's
gonna be good stuff I can't leave the
Superbowl is this weekend like next time
we do this show we'll know who won the
Superbowl and I'm officially endorsing
the Kansas City Chiefs as my team of the
Superbowl because they just did a show
in Kansas City and it was so fantastic
and I really like light to the people of
Kansas City and the vibe and I just felt
like they liked me which obviously means
I like them back and I just feel like
San Francisco like I don't know I'm not
I don't I just don't feel like it's
their time that's just my vibe
I too am indoors
in Kansas City how excited but then we
have no stake in the game like we're
doing based on like colors just know and
based on feelings and got intuition
because I'm yearning for the Travis
Kelsey's maybe if he becomes you know a
Super Bowl star they'll give him a
season two of catching Kelsey right and
for me like that is something of the
sort and I do just I have no choice but
to endorse a reality star and pro
football player like and my I find those
people those football players and
athletes who lend themselves to reality
team Eric Decker and put themselves in
the spotlight like and Kirsch McCaffrey
corpsman um date like celebrities and I
know who you are I find that they fare
better on the field
I'm just saying well that's a that is
not the case for Kroy Biermann seeing as
how he was let go from two teams like
the minute he started with the
biermann's but I was think he would have
gotten on that second team I see chance
I mean he was on the Buffalo Bills and
literally the biermann's never went to
Buffalo and like then he got like oh and
it was like it was a dark way to end his
NFL career but he had a great career on
the Atlanta Falcons and he's a hero and
I just like love the biermann's more
than life itself and I can't wait for
don't be tardy to come back which is
like never gonna happen but um I agreed
the merging of sports and reality TV is
so exciting and we have no choice but to
get involved yeah and I do think like
eight it is a value add for the team
yeah and they play better when they know
that like I know who they are it's good
press for sure I will be rooting for
catching Kelsey I'm rooting for catching
Kelsey as well I'm so exciting cool I'm
glad we're on the same team and I hope
the San Francisco toasters like don't
come for us but it's just it's not your
time it's not it's not your time I'm and
that's our expert sports opinion and I
don't know how you could argue with it
and this concludes our sports segment of
the day yes okay well we have a great
show for you today
lots of you know mindless celeb news but
nothing major but you know some of the
more quieter shows or when you know true
content comes to thrive yes when we have
to work our harness right anyways
anything else you want to share we had a
fabulous dinner last oh oh we had a
fabulous dinner last night at 11:00 ooh
and you know we're very hard on Sachs
because we went shopping there for
Olivia's wetbacks not Zak's Saks and
we're very hard on them because we went
shopping there for Olivia's wedding and
I couldn't find a dress or an employee
who worked there for like the life of us
and we like we're so hard on them but
they have a fabulous restaurant that now
just as loud as we are when we're hard
on someone we have to be just as loud
when were praised and yeah and they've
been doing all these red
and that made Sachs insufferable for the
last few years but now that the
renovations are done the first floor is
incredible like feels like a mall in
Dubai like true luxury true luxury it's
the place to be you guys it really is
the place to be everything of the sort
we went shopping a little bit we didn't
get me there actually no we didn't get
anything so we're good and then we went
up to I think I have to go back I'll
Avenue or let Avenue Avenue Avenue okay
man it's a dress me oh by the way I was
thinking this morning because not to get
serviced but like I woke up and pooped
which was so weird and it's because I
literally ate so [ __ ] much at dinner
last night like and I'm not really into
like French food but it was really
really it wasn't necessarily French food
you had a piece of grilled chicken well
yeah it's like in a French restaurant
and I did have a Thai Franklin
restaurant or just a French name I just
assumed it was French and oh the menu
was in French in English was it which
was so annoying that's French yeah right
and very exciting because we got seen it
literally right next to Hannah brown and
her parents did and Margo who we said on
the show is Hannah Brown's like number
one fan like Stan's till she dies and
Margo was literally staring at Hannah
and her parents the whole meal I switch
seats with Margo so she could get a beer
and then towards the end Margo was very
you know conscious of being respectful
and when you're out to dinner with you
when you see a celebrity after dinner
with their family like there's pretty
much a rule like you don't interrupt
like there's levels of respect so Margo
waited like about two hours and they
were just still sitting there like
having ice cream in champagne which was
so cute and as we were getting ready to
go Margo went and just said her piece
she didn't ask for a picture she just
said hi in the snatchler I have a
bachelor pad cast I like literally love
you and only say nice things about you
like I just want you to know I love love
love love love and support you and I
took a couple pictures of Margo talking
to Hannah so she would have that like
for the memories but Margo got back and
was like literally like how you would
act if you met Kim Kardashian yeah she
was hooked to the [ __ ] core
honestly I know we're hard on Hannah on
the show but just seeing her have like a
lovely dinner with her parents she's a
lovely New York City like she's a lovely
girl
she was just showing up like looking
cute no makeup like she's I think she's
everything of the sort I think she might
be I think she might be too yeah I think
the snatcher might have been right about
that one I think so too
anyways it was really such such a lovely
evening I'm I'm hungry talking about it
and I'm actually starving I find that
the more you eat at night the hunger you
are in the morning
maybe I'm just like always hungry I'm
trying to make excuses for like why I'm
hungry at certain times yeah it's just
me it's just life it's just life well
let's get into it because I think it's
time do you I think so there was no time
like the present so it is time for the
past five stories that you need to know
yes you before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast for sure
you know since I'm not here to like
embarrass you on our big pot for I'm in
like me and like make you feel like what
you just said was incorrect because it
is correct it is time sounds like you're
gonna embarrass me like what I said was
incorrect I'm not gonna embarrass you
I'm just simply going to let everyone
know that today's episode is brought to
you by OkCupid have you ever been on a
date with someone where you just had
nothing in common with the person a lot
of people don't know this but OkCupid
has really changed the dating game by
asking you tons of questions about
yourself and what type of person you're
looking for the more questions you
answer the better they are at finding
you matches that you have something in
common with some of our favorite
questions from their profile are are you
a morning person do you make New Year's
resolutions
could you date someone who couldn't be
bothered to vote and by the way OkCupid
works statistically it is the most
mentioned dating app in the New York
Times wedding section which i think is
like the best endorsement you could ever
have for a dating app stop the mindless
time on dating apps and go to the app
where you choose what matters OkCupid is
completely free so we don't have to give
you a very long link or a code just
download it keep it today go on a great
day this week and then tell us about
that great person you met will come to
the wedding and you know what OkCupid
pays me to say that I'll come to the
wedding but what they don't pay me to
say is that if you meet someone on
OkCupid because I told you to go I will
personally show up at your wedding as
long as you find me for his class and I
will sing a song I was singing down the
aisle and then officiate the wedding I
will get ordained online so if that's
not enough of a ringing endorsement I
don't know what is yeah you don't want
it badly enough yeah okay first story
some exciting bebut news Ciara is
pregnant with baby number three everyone
has been like announcing babies this
week in the morning yes yes they were
recording yesterday which is why it
wasn't a story um but I'm so happy for
them I love that family because it this
is exactly what we were talking about a
convergence of celebrity and sport
Russel Wilson who's like one of the
highest-paid NFL players but like I
stand him because Ciara talks about him
unwatched happens live you know yeah I
don't I don't know his accolades on the
the field I'm sure they're fabulous
fabulous but I'm more concerned with its
accolades as a husband and a father and
and husband of Ciara no and it's like
when you are dating a celeb or when
you're dating anyone and you're having
babies and you're getting married and
you're really happy like that does
positively affect your performance in
the field it just does and it seems like
it's really affecting the performance in
a highly positive way even though he's
not in the Super Bowl but like whatever
neither is time rating but it's like oh
do you get paid extra for winning the
Super Bowl for sure think you get a
bonus definitely but then you also get a
big contract remember Andy was asking
her about it it's highest in NFL history
and so I guess it'll be nice for them to
have a quiet week um to themselves even
if you don't get like a bonus for
winning the Super Bowl you become a
bigger star and then like more
opportunities to make money elsewhere
we're Instagram followers yeah the
world's biggest stage it is it is for
JLo JLo and Shakira have been doing a
ton of press and they're so cute they're
so cute JLo had a Judith Leiber football
bag she's everything she's everything of
the sort nobody lied to her we're gonna
beat this joke and that's what we do and
the mean was on to the next one I feel
like if only we could like keep it
forever at a normal like level we can't
I can't it's not that big of the sort
okay Ciara and Russell Wilson are
growing their family the 34 year old
singer is expecting her third child the
star announced the happy news by sharing
a photo of herself posing in a bikini
and baring her baby bump on Instagram
it's just unfair like I'm not pregnant
and I'll literally never take a picture
in a bikini but like Sarah is pregnant
and she's taking a picture in a bikini
and looking better than like me then
I'll ever look but it's it is fair
because it's like Ciara so if there's
anyone who's gonna do it it's gonna be
her she's literally she is the snatchler
do you remember when we were kids there
was like rumors that she was a
hermaphrodite yeah that was so weird and
[ __ ] up it's very strange and she's
nothing thank you exactly
also Russell Wilson posted like a selfie
with her in the background it's just
like love a person who makes it about
themselves oh by the way when we wrote
number three no choice but to respect a
celebrity who makes everything about
themselves because we are everything of
the sort yes we are also it's her first
child is with her teacher's future and
it's so sweet that he captioned at
number three it's like his third kid
like I totally totally embracing a
fountain family I love it's like they
watched blended no tell you what to do
it's like they listen to Teddy
Mellencamp
cast i weirdly found myself listening to
a clip of her podcast and you know I
never really realized and I don't think
they've ever addressed on the show how
they her Ned Wayne have three kids and
the oldest kid is Edwin's from a first
marriage oh that's how blended they are
right and the the old KITT the older
girl looks just like the middle girl who
is Teddy's biological daughter so I
guess they just never realized that she
had a different mom and Teddy wasn't her
biological mom and I heard her talking
about like how it came to be how she met
Edwin when she was so young and she just
like never expected to like marry
someone with a child and how like it's
so seamlessly integrated and it's really
like ideal I you know usually there's
like you know bad blood like Oh cuz you
know she was on sorry she was on Randall
and Lala's podcast and Lala was talking
about how her foray into co-parenting
started out like really toxic remember
there was so much drama with Lala
putting the kids on her Instagram and
then Randall's ex-wife aka the mom and
the kids was like really upset and it
was like so much drama like being
spilled out in like a public way but
Teddy has this like ideal situation when
her family's like so seamlessly blended
and it's just like we have no choice but
to respect that yeah but I think it also
takes time like worse I'm sure it wasn't
so easy from the get-go and now instead
he has other kids with Edwin they have
this family and I think for Lala and
Randall the situation like is different
there's how many kids 2 or 3 2 and it's
it's like of course that one also
Randall left yeah I love Lala's look but
of course his ex-wife is pissed
ya know it's not only is like la la like
everything like who wouldn't hate her
Randall left his family for Lala
right and now like Lala's posting
pictures of the kids and like I
understand I the great I never
understood something so clearly in my
life I'm not comparing the two but it
was just like it was interesting because
I don't feel like Teddy doesn't really
talk about that I just assumed not to
say that older daughter was Teddy's but
that's what happens when you blend so
well right it's literally you can't see
you can't see what Part A and Part B
were it's a vertical integration blended
it's complete integration vertical and
horizontal we were in a blender now
saving life okay
next story because we haven't talked
about her all week and I'm having with
Charles let me guess um last week we
talked about this person all week this
week we haven't talked about this
campaign yet
no I don't know last week no you can get
it what was last week oh yeah I forgot
what this came
last week okay we even dedicated an
episode title to this person because
Megan Marco oh it was two weeks ago
because we were talking about this
person Jessica Simpson yes okay
Jeff still excited for her book when
does it go around like any minute now
you pre-order something on Amazon it
shows up at your house the day that it
comes out so it's really mailed the day
before sir well so let's say less yet
peak you know postman have real power no
one talks about yeah like I'm always
like let's say hypothetically there's a
postman out there who's a toaster like
hypothetically I'm always mailing stuff
and the only mail stuff emails like
boring serious stuff and it says my name
on it so like you could open it up and
like find likes my tax returns or
something you know yeah I'm not gonna
give anyone any ideas I need to come up
with like a code name
yeah for myself in the mail industry
yeah I mean it also is it like a federal
crime yeah and by the way postman like
respect the mail like they respect the
[ __ ] out of the mail they take it very
serious there's lots of postman laws and
I just some I'm you know what they do
hard work I just I do want to know if
anyone's let's saying are you a postman
and a toaster or a post woman sorry post
person if you are someone who works in a
post office person a post person and
you're a toaster I just need to know if
you exist and if you ever like see like
interesting now and yeah yeah yeah or
like you know it's an interesting job
like being a post person like in
Calabasas for sure
even though I feel like real celebrities
don't take chance on mail they have like
messengers and stuff yeah and then they
also do like that ex overnight right now
but every FedEx person or maybe there's
like a true like mail service for the
elites hmm I don't know if that's a big
enough business yeah it's very nice it's
like what you have to do a whole plane
ride for like one envelope right where
it's like you send your assistant yeah
okay Jessica Simpson reveals she once
kissed Justin Timberlake who then texted
his Mickey Mouse Club co-star Ryan
Gosling we are dead what among the many
revelations in her upcoming memoir open
book Jessica's and she shares a story
about Ryan Gosling and Justin Timberlake
and involves some kissing and telling
Simpson appeared on Jimmy Kimmel Live
Wednesday night and revealed that she
once kissed Justin Timberlake following
her divorce from ex Nick Lachey in 2005
quote
the divorce and he Justin was out of a
relationship he was over at my house and
we shared a nostalgic kiss and I thought
oh this is interesting
the starch-filled Kimmel and he took his
phone out and started typing and I was
like okay I hope that's not another girl
that's should I like to stick my tongue
out too much or something but Gosling
and Timberlake had a bet that Simpson
didn't know about dating back to when
they co-starred on The Mickey Mouse Club
in 1993 this is a true rom-com ahmed's
she's all that's like totally apparently
him and got Ryan Gosling had a bet on
who would kiss me first when they were
12 years old and so he texted Ryan and
said he won the bet Simpson continued
and I was like oh okay um so we don't
kiss again that's done I'm well that's
so weird um I'm sorry but like I know
I'm so hard on him but Justin to really
get such a loser like I can't like
Jackie I couldn't agree more and I have
no regrets for being hard on him like he
actually sucks and I just think he's
like a fraud and I think he's truly the
definition of nothing of the sort like
he should be with my kind of totally but
like I actually like their facets of his
life I really like like I think his
marriage with Jessica Biel is cute and
they like what stood the test of time
and Hollywood whatever yeah and I think
like him holding hands to the co-stars
I'm really cute yeah I just think that
like his music career is truly nothing
of the sort
and I he gives me like my Lisa actually
no because you know what Justin
Timberlake actually is very talented and
there's a reason why like JC shisei is
where he is and Justin Timberlake it's
where he is like he he manifested out of
like the boyband curse and he was like a
star but there was like a period of time
when he was about like respected as like
the next Michael Jackson like he got the
Vanguard Award he did that huge
performance like a 30 minute thing like
and I just feel like it was really
premature like giving him all those
accolades because he hadn't really done
that much I understand why people are
confused and think he's everything of
the sort like there's a mass confusion
amongst Americans what's his song called
like with the mayor and by the way like
jay-z made that song like what it is
like it's like I'm Amira Oh mommy was
telling you guys that song [ __ ] sucks
actually now that I'm singing it yeah I
actually like it oh and what about the
back turn get me started anyway in the
time period it was released in like it
was everything of the sort okay that's
what people thought because like they
put josie and the pussycats programming
into the song but it was nothing of the
sort
like it was nothing of the sort
today I just want I really like that
song mirror I forgot about it what's
that what's the song he had with jay-z
uh 2020 that was the album look it up
Holy Grail oh that's an amazing singer
but that's oh that's an amazing song
that's all jay-z I'm sorry that's what
I'm saying it's like it defied the odds
of Justin Timberlake right even though
just one more time I want to go back and
say oh ma Mira staring back me and he
also has can't stop the feeling and I'll
give him that because that is the song
of a generation yeah but it's mostly
like trolls wrote the song and gave it
to him yeah / Potter by the way if can't
stop the feeling had come out during
like the tick tock age it would have
been huge on tick tock can I also just
say I'm really getting annoyed it's like
an OG tick tock er like oh you're not
gonna cheat a kegger no I am I have a
musically but now it's like literally
every celebrity is flocking to tick tock
making it an account only when they have
a new song and then making a video like
do all it by this morning guys
I just physical it's now available on
tick tock can't wait to see what you do
with it it's like you can't make a song
go viral on tick tock like it just
happens and like it doesn't even mean
that the song is like the best in the
world it just means it's part of the
algorithm that is tick tock so it's just
so thirsty of all these people like
flocking and being like check out my new
challenge even though the Jonas Brothers
didn't make a great what a man gotta do
challenge and it went like a caught fire
yeah I would agree with that like we're
not here to like serve you in your
challenge you know it's like we're out
here making organic content out of songs
we genuinely love and just like
expressing ourselves and now your
marketing dollars are coming in and like
infiltrating that [ __ ] off yeah [ __ ] off
I really it rubbed me the wrong way okay
Oh suit-and-tie Oh terrible so terrible
right like I'm telling you guys I'm onto
something like we have been brain not me
you guys have been brainwashed to think
and especially my husband like loves
Justin Timberlake God better your
husband it is Justin Timberlake you know
that right I know he's like Justin
Timberlake with like cuteness and talent
how you hate Justin Timberlake so much
but then ended up marrying Justin
Timberlake is crazy no it's like they
look exactly alike
what do you they don't look alike yes
they do no they don't no I'm thinking we
literally saw him last night oh my god I
was out to dinner with Justin Timberlake
okay I guess that's cool cuz like other
people think Justin Timberlake well we
didn't say he wasn't hot doesn't ever
like it's hot
no he's not meat I know I mean either
but arbitrarily like he's a good-looking
guy like
from a third party I don't know I don't
know what arbiters you're talking to but
I just
so buddy today thanks because I'm back
I'm in the air ya know and I'm just like
not pulling my weight because I'm back
on the air
okay well I feel like you just wanted to
share something and I'm not gonna stop
you I want to get something off my chest
that's really actually been bothering me
um and it's hard for me like to not get
all choked up about how much I love
article winter is a time of celebration
and renewal with endless to-do lists
making memories with loved ones and
setting goals for the future article is
here to help you make the season
stress-free and beautiful with stackable
extra seating sofa beds extendable
tables and multi-purpose poof's article
selection of stylish furniture makes it
easy to find just what you're looking
for this is such an appropriate ad for
us today because we have a new studio
and we literally just got here we're
already growing out of it and it's it's
time for multi-purpose furniture you
know it is it is time we need stackable
extra seating sofa beds like that's
everything of the sort in terms of what
we need as we start a new year it's time
to start working under 20/20 vision
keep your eyes peeled and your Instagram
open for sneak peeks of articles latest
sales articles the easiest way to make
your space look beautiful it's
direct-to-consumer furniture company
that combines the curation of a boutique
furniture store with a comfort and
simplicity of shopping online articles
team of designers focus on beautifully
crafted pieces quality materials and
durable construction they are dedicated
to a modern aesthetic of mid-century
Scandinavian industrial and bohemian
designs it's fast affordable flat rate
shipping is available across the US and
Canada free orders on over free on
orders or over 999 dollars plus
additional options for in-room delivery
and assembly assistance all in stock
items are delivered in two weeks or less
their prices are fair you can save up to
30% over traditional retail prices they
keep their prices low by cutting out the
middleman and selling directly to you I
just have to say I got something from
article like over a year ago and it is
we stood the test of time like my bed is
not from article and because being
better like always like romping around
on it like not even in the dirty way
like it's not what stood the test of
time we have to get a new one because
the little wood panels on the bottom are
fully breaking but what I got from
article has done truly withstood the
test of time it doesn't even look like
it's been broken in and trust me it has
but you also got 30 days to make up your
mind with simple returns and exchanges
article is offering our listeners $50
off their first purchase of $100 or more
to claim visit article
calm / toast and the discount will
automatically be applied at checkout
that's article dot-com / toast to get
$50 off your first purchase of $100 or
more sign on get furniture that will
withstand the test of time people are
that should be there hard for you Justin
Timberlake in the comments I'm sure and
they keep bringing up song titles I'm
like oh thank you for the reminder I
hate that song too this show should be
called in the morning unpopular opinion
senorita senorita I don't know I'm
having an adverse reaction like every
time someone's bringing up a song like
Jim I would dance such [ __ ] at a wedding
oh my god no I'm like get that song but
I think you might be feeling that way
because they were so big that whatever
hissongk it becomes huge like you
automatically hate it no but I don't
feel this way about every artist that's
popular no and you know what song I feel
has withstood the test of time in terms
of like becoming huge and me not hating
it was Bo dak yellow like that song
comes on and I'm still like [ __ ]
throwing down in the club
yeah for sure no it's just a great song
ok it's every one of the song let's move
on because I don't want to like hurt you
guys anymore
but I meant what I said next story Lori
Loughlin and Massimo Jian Uli have
listed their bel-air mansion for twenty
eight million dollars oh do you think
they need the money for course of course
that's like my first inclination but
upon reading the details no Lori
Loughlin and Massimo Julian newly have
listed their sprawling Beller pad where
they were laying low after being
implicated in the college admissions
scandal for more than twenty eight
million dollars according to a new
report the actress and fashion designer
quietly put their mansion located in one
of the ritziest
areas of Los Angeles on the market for
twenty eight point six five zero zero
zero zero sources told CMC on Thursday
CMZ yep it's new it's a new news outlet
like they have all like what did you
mean to say teams no cm American that's
what I meant
my favorite way I said what I meant I
said what I said but the decision had
nothing to do with the college
admissions scandal or the celebrities
pears upcoming trial the source said
they are simply quote following
Massimo's passion for architecture the
alley reported the couple purchased the
12,000 square foot estate with six
bedrooms and nine baths for thirteen
point nine million dollars in 2015
I mean list of like the reasons why
which the reasons you just said it
sounded like the biggest lie of the
world
it must be sad like for Olivia and Bella
like they're not going through enough
another losing their childhoods on their
child at home they only lived there
since 2015 and
we know that Olivia doesn't live there
anymore right anyone tell her that and
maybe they're just um what's it called
downsizing right I want to talk about
that I honestly I'm not really
interested in the house of it all and
honestly in this whole College Admission
scandal like I don't really care about
Lori and mosk email like I'm just really
like concerned about Olivia Jade and she
joined tick-tock and she put up two tick
tocks both of them with her boyfriend
who like I haven't really invested time
in like learning about and her second
take Jack was a video of him sitting at
the piano playing hey now you're an all
sorry but like acoustic and like he was
like putting his own Flair on it I guess
he's a singer and the video like I'm in
love with him like it's he's such a good
singer and it was such a good piano
player and really like has a love for
the music I just got the vibe from tick
tock and I just think everyone should
follow around tick tock it's a really
premium platform for her Wow I'm I will
check it out both videos are like in a
black and white aesthetic I do hope she
evolved past the black and white but
it's very her yeah
I don't know what her vibe it's like her
right now
like she's so email she's so email but
like wouldn't you me yeah um this house
is beautiful
it makes you wonder like not yeah like
are they struggling financially neither
of them are working but like I think
they're trying I'm pretty sure they're
fine like Massimo has that target money
he has a lot of money but like they also
live a very big life and like that
require expenses and it's constant
upkeep totally sustained
yeah I love when they show pictures of
celebrities houses like from an aerial
view because you really get to see how
big they are yeah and it's like they
skimped on the gardening over there you
know that's not their property maybe but
then that's kind of a small backyard
yeah but remember it's from aerial view
maybe they're coming back maybe maybe
the gardening is just too high it's
possible you never know just can't
stress enough how good Olivia Jade steak
tacos Wow ringing endorsement from the
og of tick tock from the og up to talk
and the person who's putting out like
the most premium content on Tech Talk
and is getting literally no hype follow
me at girl with no job okay
next story really crazy Lisa
Vanderpump's Dog Foundation is being
sued for sexual harassment to the dogs
no an employee okay the Vanderpump dog
foundation was hit with a sexual
harassment and wrongful termination
lawsuit by a former employee
damiana Guzman according to court
documents obtained by page six six on
Thursday gozman claimed that she worked
as a dog groomer for two months and
resigned in july 2019 quote because of
the intolerable working conditions
created by her
manager Martin Duarte and his superiors
she alleged that Duarte quote mocked her
by calling her things such as a skinny
no ass fool and a flat ass [ __ ] he also
told her that he didn't know how her
girlfriend could stand to be with her
because she had no ass ooh
Guzman also claimed that he told her
that quote he could turn her straight
just like he did to the mother of his
child oh my god she alleged that not a
day went by where Duarte didn't make a
comment about her body her sexual
preference or his sexual prowess and
that she complained to higher-up she
believed that no disciplinary action was
taken so she resigned well I mean it
just sucks like that Lisa Vanderpump
because she's so famous I'm like her
name is on all of her businesses like
you automatically read this article and
you just associated her as being like a
sexual predator when she's not and
that's not the case but if it does turn
out that this woman complained to
higher-ups like nobody did anything like
then that's problematic yeah and it's
not like Vanderpump dogs is you know
this national chain where there's all
these franchises and you can't help what
goes on like it's one source she's there
all the time I see on the show the
higher-ups what that's John says John
Dear John 3:16 like and we know that
they're probably and they're in Lisa's
house sylia it's not she's not so far
romantic yeah that's true julissa isn't
committing these crimes but she's like
this is the culture going on right under
her nose right no she clay like she
prides herself on being so involved in
her businesses right as we see on the
show like they forced down our throats
right but we know that John blizzard and
John says so like our morally corrupt so
honestly this is the least shocking
thing I've heard all day
yeah Wow John's I feel like also Lisa
and specifically Vanderpump dogs like
cannot catch a break they're always
getting sued yeah
Kenzo he's getting sued but he was
shoved a woman which is also not
shocking if you've seen him put his
finger and you'll have a head beats face
and calling her a stupid woman so this
is the least shocking news I've heard
all day yeah um we'll keep you posted
fifth and final story a little is news
its business already it's business
already that actually makes sense
because our sponsor of business is
brought to you by fiber
Oh perfect sponsor for the business talk
about finding freelance talent for your
business or project that's [ __ ]
hard the right freelancer can be time
finding the right freelancer can be
time-consuming frustrating and expensive
how do you how much does it cost where
do you go to find the person how can you
be certain that they'll actually deliver
thanks to Fiverr finding the right
freelancer doesn't have to be a struggle
their marketplace helps you get more
done with less fiber connects businesses
with freelancers who offer a hundred of
digital services including graphic
design copywriting web programming film
editing and more as a startup business
like we are you constantly looking and
using freelancers and the Fiverr
marketplace has been really helpful for
us you can search by service deadline
price reviews and more you'll know
exactly what you're paying for upfront
no negotiation needed it's 24/7 customer
service but it's quality talent you can
count on their sellers have worked with
some of the best and most influential
brands in the world finding talent for
your project has never been easier you
can review seller ratings by your
feedback and select the right freelancer
based on your budget take five and check
out Fiverr and you will receive 10% off
your first order by using code toast so
easy don't waste any more time get the
service you deserve by going to fiv eerr
comm use the code toast fiverr.com FIV
ER our fiber comm code toasts fiber it
starts here sign-on start here
okay for the final story that you
mentioned at dinner last night and stock
soars on huge earnings beat Prime
membership record okay I have some
theories about this Jeff Bezos his net
worth went up twelve billion dollars
last night Amazon blew Wall Street's
expectations out of the water when it
reported earnings for the holiday
quarter sending the company stock up
over 12.5 percent in after-hours trading
on Thursday the company posted profits
of 3.3 billion or six dollars and forty
cents seven cents per share compared to
the analysts expectations of two billion
so in the holiday season what do you
consider the holiday season like
Thanksgiving to Christmas New Year's or
q4
Oh q4 so that's the last three months ah
yes also so they obviously did well
Prime membership set a record high and I
just want to say I think it's cuz of
Kasey Musgraves it's a Christmas special
why do you think that because like that
one of these things is not like the
other it was there right is gone prime
crime it was their biggest quarter ever
gay but when you think of Prime
membership it's not just video it's
paying for that two-day shipping which
in the holiday season you literally
can't put a price on good shipping you
can't put a price on it but like video
and content like that's where it's at
and an according to Leeanne Locken the
post office does lose 30% of its mail
per year
which is an incorrect statistic but like
during the holiday season and even with
our business like shipping stuff like
it's so treacherous and the holiday
season is like heightened for packages
getting lost and Amazon has their
shipping like so [ __ ] tight yeah that
if you're buying something for someone
as a gift like you're gonna buy it on
Amazon yeah I mean I inadvertently
apparently I'm a prime member and I
think it's just because I started
watching crime videos and then they were
like charging me I've been a prime
member since college because you got a
really good price for having a college
like student discount and then I just
never cancelled it when I got full price
charge and I literally didn't even care
I don't even know how much prime is I
don't know when I get charged but every
year every year it's like oh here's
we're taking $100 and I'm like literally
take five I don't care take take it all
take fiber take fiber um
agreed I'm happy for Jeff Bezos because
he's had like I mean I know he's like so
rich and whatnot but like personally I
feel like he's had a rough year yeah and
by the way it's crazy that his net worth
is now 130 billion when he got divorced
he had to give away like almost 40
billion so his net worth got cut in half
but now he's totally recovered yeah and
he's back to 130 but yes back to his
personal life I feel like we like really
quickly stop talking about that and by
the way when the toaster started the
Jeff Bezos challenge like that was
funniest thing ever like I just want to
give a moment to the toasters who
started that um but I feel like recently
like some news has come out about like
the text messages and how it was like
all released by his girlfriend Lauren
Sanchez and they're still together and
they're still together it's so weird to
me it's like almost like Jeff Bezos has
low self-esteem ya know it's like Jeff
Bezos is so smart but he's so dumb
honestly like who would you set Jeff
Bezos up with um do I not like he's like
he needs someone age-appropriate and
Lauren Sanchez actually is
age-appropriate she's not like 25 um but
she's thirsty like you need someone
who's six honestly low key like him she
knows how to handle like a rich man she
really does she knows how to run a
household and give good BJ's she says
yeah and that's that's her contribution
that's honestly like a great call I know
or like maybe a friend of Lila and she
can like show them how it's done
even though literally this morning I was
thinking weirdly about Lala and Randall
when I was doing my makeup and and like
obviously like if you look at them like
she like it looks like a gold digger
like she's 25 and so sexy and he's like
him but I Loki like believe in their
love
Voki Heike i believe in it so hard i
believe in it like i don't think that
like obviously she enjoys all the perks
of being Randall's mrs. Randall but I
really feel like they're truly in love
and like if let's say something happened
and he went bankrupt like she would stay
with him I agree I think that they're 11
I think she like he changed her life
like obviously like the clout but also
like the sobriety like I just think that
they're really good for each other
I completely agree okay I just feel like
that's not said enough but it's like
because James is always like that man
paying your bills like and by the way
that's like funny and like could have
been true but I don't think that it is
no it's not maybe it was once the case
but it's no longer have you heard the
new cash a song tonight oh my god I
played it this morning I was getting
ready the beginning I was like oh my god
yes Kesha like we are back let's go and
then the beat drops and I was like trash
it's the worst song ever written but
that's not why I bring it up there's
like a man who comes on in like raps and
it literally sounds like James Kennedy
make it that far
oh you have to listen I was like it
sounds like the blight Kanye I couldn't
stand the song it really sounds like him
I would love to know if anybody else had
a similar thought process i listening to
Margo's started playlist on Spotify
that's how I keep up with the kids and
like the tick tock jams and I was
listening to this trash song and I might
oh my god his his James Kennedy I
thought maybe for one second mugger like
put James Kennedy a song okay who was
the future on the song I mean I'm sure I
did but I didn't give it that much like
time and investment that would be an
easy way to find out if it was she know
it obviously wasn't there would be like
more people talking about it but yeah
but we would be the ones talking about
it and here we are
can I get a name and that Ke$ha song is
good okay done vitsin of creation she
really she really rhymed creation with
amen
good for her yeah she's really like a
songstress and a lyricist so this song
is really shocking it feels like she was
trying to like recapture the magic of
tick-tock wait yeah oh my god I just put
that together tick tock tick tock on the
clock but also tick tock stole that from
her sure yeah Chuck Chuck okay wait I
have one more story because everyone's
been pinging me to talk about it the
crown has announced that they will be
ending the show with season 5 on Netflix
no um as imelda staunton is confirmed as
the final queen okay so season 3 just
came out are you deaf so we're gonna get
two more seasons I'm devastated because
I love the show but I'm also mad at them
they somewhat I'm reading like they
think that the end of season 5 is the
perfect time and place to stop why
because they have to start getting into
some kind they're gonna start to take
some sighs like I think I think this is
a coward
when we've been talking about the crown
you've been speaking about sorry when
we've been talking about the drama in
the royal family you've been speaking
about the crown like it's gonna live
forever and you're like oh I can't wait
in five years to see how they address
what happens now like this show could go
on forever as long as you know the
monarchy is going on and I think I just
don't want to deal with the controversy
honestly it feels like maybe like Megan
and Harry have like a Netflix to go and
part of their deal was like you have to
end the crown because this is just weird
timing don't you agree yeah crazy
conspiracy but it's like definitely
conspiracy but by the time end up having
some sort of show on Netflix or like
their philanthropy has some show on
Netflix mark my words this is why the
crown was cancelled I'm not trying to be
too spirited theorist but talk to me in
a year well here's the team we're a
watchers mean hoping the crown might be
extended to Prince Harry and Megan
Markel's megsie or the fallout from
Prince Andrew's relationship with
Jeffrey Epstein are set to be
disappointed me but does that mean
they're gonna do Diana well Diana was
primed for next season because like
Camilla parker-bowles was they're really
coming up on like the modern era it's
not like the 1900s and you know it was
never it was always the 1900s it started
in the 1950s and we're about to hit like
the 80s oh we're getting close yeah
we're getting close
um but so this coming season season four
will be about Diana probably okay season
five would be about anything dating
Diana and no Kate is like mm I don't
think they'd be just skipping decade or
maybe Fergie like not interested well
that's so crazy yeah I don't know
sometimes they they harp so long I'm
like a month and sometimes you skip over
a few years I mean Diana has been
portrayed in like a million movies and
documentaries so it's not like crazy
that they would be like talking about
Diana or like being make taking aside
but Suri has kind of already didn't
written right but with Harry and Megan
like they obviously just don't wanna be
the ones to write history but like
someone's got to Melanie Bromley is or
maybe just show it as it happened I
actually like when they give like a
notice like hey we're gonna have two
more seasons like when you're watching a
show you get invested and then you find
out like it's cancelled that sucks like
being able to come like shits Creek we
knew for the last two seasons that we're
gonna be ending this year and like it
makes it easier to wrap up the story and
Dan levy in every interview he says he
says that's very much a pretty
like not every person just gets to
decide when their show ends like usually
like the network cancels it but so so
I'm grateful but so it makes for a
viewer it makes it more premium I guess
knowing that you got some time to come
to terms with the fact that the crown is
ending ok apparently the seat the series
is gonna end in 2003 oh it said what the
article says that's what Handel ouble
says oh okay well and she seems sure
about that 2003 so that's not Kate
that's not Megan that's not Harry that's
William and and Harry just like growing
up yeah boring boring I think it's
disappointing like hate to see it truly
hate to see I'll obviously keep watching
but um we're seeing miss Americana
tonight so if you came to our show to
watch this recap it we have been
avoiding Netflix since 3:00 a.m. and I'm
gonna avoid it all day avoid all
spoilers we're going to the movies
tonight so I'm excited about that so if
you're looking for a recap we will recap
it on Monday we release two new patreon
episode last night our fifth and final
of the month just like a Q&A we've
gotten a lot of questions this month
about like families top it was actually
really interesting and I think my
favorite part of the episode was at the
end when we accidentally like told each
other like when sisters like talk [ __ ]
like what do they say about each other
yeah like what's like one word that just
keeps coming up bright night like
there's a sign we each have a stigma
yeah I've asked my friends that to you
before cuz it's like I could tell you
what the common theme when we talk [ __ ]
about you like what people say about you
you know I know what the common theme
with my friends is like I don't show up
and I think I'm like a star and honestly
I am NOT wrong and once I might force
them at cuz they used to be like no we
don't really say what did they say um
and then like one time Deena told me
that's like E oh you know what but like
if you if you can own your flakiness
like that's not hurtin hurt my feeling
now when it's like I know that I'm flaky
and like oh so that is the worst thing
that I'm doing oh good to know I'm a
great friend that everywhere else in the
house uh bored right so it was really
funny episode check it out
patreon.com/scishow Steny thing else we
need to plug phone in Instagram clogged
with no job follow Theo pup within a job
follow me Jackie Oh problems yeah we I'm
really excited for the weekend it's been
a long week about 177 K we've been
talking about our Instagram a lot here
at the morning toast feel free to follow
us we're almost at 2:00 in turkey and I
feel like once my 200 like we're a real
show like 100 obviously like is
everything but nice but 200 like you're
into the hundreds yeah like there's no
there's no accidentally dipping under
hundred
yeah I think that like we can go back to
two digits no and we never would we're
nothing of the sort
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast millennium morning show
where we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so if
you're following us on YouTube make sure
to check in leave a five star comment
you know whatever we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcasts can be
found so that Spotify iTunes stitcher
public radio I Heart Radio cashbox
wherever you choose to listen to podcast
find us subscribe leave a review about
how beautiful stunning and smart we are
we love you guys so much have an amazing
weekend go drink clausal ah don't drink
and drive we love you take pictures in
your toast merch head over to shop
morning toast comm we have a few flasks
left so check it out for the tipsy
toaster in your life I hope you're using
you're tipsy toaster fast this weekend
you should bring yours to the movies
tonight
yes and take a picture and send it to us
yeah bye